dans le sud tourelles ou grand pressigny
haut lieu de la préhistoire
une femme va s'illustrer henriette
lecointe tout à la fois royalistes et
féministe elle va se prendre de passion
pour tous et silex taillés et autres
falun au point de devenir une
paléontologue chevronné
avec son mari pierre lecointre eh bien
venez découvrir ces falun elle va s'y
intéresser et petit à petit on va voir
que d'autodidacte va de manière
spécialistes elle a commencé à écrire
des livres et puis il y a le catalogue
dans lequel elle a donc répertorié tous
qu'elle avait découvert
elle a constitué une collection où au
fil des années et puis son garçon
georges lecointe il a été élevé dans
cette passion là également il a
rencontré justement tous ces grands
géologue et paléontologue la passion lui
est venue aussi et c'est lui qui va
faire des études et qui va être connu et
qui va être la référence
visible dans ce musée de la préhistoire
leurs collections porte aujourd'hui le
nom du fils
une simple photo il ya descriptif
présente henriette lecointe aux
visiteurs pourraient pourtant si
facilement rendre justice à cette femme
de science